el fin de la era castro el presidente
raúl castro quien cumplirá 90 años en
junio renunció a la jefatura del partido
comunista de cuba en lo que a mí se
refiere
concluyen y tarea como primer secretario
del comité central del partido comunista
de cuba
con la satisfacción de haber cumplido y
la confianza en el futuro de la patria
con la meditada convicción de no aceptar
propuestas para mantenerme en los
hombros superiores de la organización
partidista en cuya actividad
continua revolucionario más el congreso
que se celebra cada cinco años es la
reunión en la que se elige a la
dirección del partido y se establecen
las directrices políticas que marcan el
rumbo de cuba en 2016 raúl castro dijo
que sería la última sesión dirigida por
la llamada generación histórica de
veteranos revolucionarios ahora por
primera vez en más de 60 años un partido
único de la isla no tendrá un miembro de
la familia castro al frente y será el
actual mandatario miguel díaz canel
designado por castro quien tomará el
relevo al frente del partido como hizo
con la presidencia en 2018 sería el
último en ocupar este cargo pero bueno
está el relevo el relevo que está
instruido está capacitado y creo que
nuestro país salga adelante con esto el
cambio en la dirección se produce cuando
cuba afronta su peor crisis económica en
décadas grabada por la pandemia y las
sanciones impuestas en los últimos días
de la administración trump muchos
cubanos esperan mejoras sociales
tengo estar a salvo en el congreso esto
mejor es donde te repito porque los
pérez están muy altos
subieron los salarios yo sería lo mismo
eso es por gusto porque en definitiva no
alcanza sin embargo los analistas
apuntan a que la nueva generación de
jóvenes líderes hagan cambios poco
radicales en el modelo político cubano